hoy vamos a echar un vistazo a una
lámpara de toque vamos a ver de qué está
hecha y que tiene adentro y observa como
si sólo la presión se enciende y después
para pagarla la presión es de nuevo la
lámpara de toque parece un domo de
acrílico opaco que permite a la luz
extenderse y tener un brillo suave y
además tiene este borde o bisel de
estireno poliestireno así que vamos a
quitar todos los tornillos son cuatro
tornillos de acero recubiertos de zinc
hay que sacarlos
así que déjame remover también estos
tornillos que faltan
aquí se quedaron un par de tornillos
todavía hay que sacarlos y bueno voy a
dejar las baterías en su lugar porque
quiero mostrarles cómo se ve la luz sin
la tapa esto cuando la luz está
encendida bien ya por fin terminamos de
quitar todos los tornillos por acá
puedes observar que este es el
compartimiento de las baterías tenemos
cuatro baterías doble am y ahora vamos a
quitar el bice esta es la parte superior
la cubierta superior y luego tenemos
este reflector de luz y puede saltar que
no es perfectamente transparente y esto
es intencional ya que le permite a la
luz rebotar mucho más esto es porque las
superficies opacas son más difusas y
hacen que la luz salga con un brillo más
suave y si quitamos estas superficies
opacas obtenemos una luz muy intensa es
más vamos a verlo justo así es como se
ve sin la cubierta
y ahora si se la ponemos así es como se
ve con la cubierta
puedes ver como esto ayuda a suavizar la
luz ya extenderla si quitamos esta parte
nuestro seguro si lo ven en la cámara
aquí tenemos una luz más intensa y
cuando ponemos de nuevo el reflector de
luz este nos ayuda a suavizar la luz y
extenderla pero bueno ahora vamos a ver
las partes que tiene adentro tenemos por
aquí unos resortes y estos resortes
hacen que la cubierta regrese a su
posición normal tenemos tres resortes
diferentes voy a quitarlos y después por
acá tenemos un diodo emisor de luz
este es un diodo emisor de luz blanco
ahora viene un diodo emisor de luz o
cualquier tipo de diodo necesita que la
corriente viajen en una sola dirección
básicamente actúa como una válvula
digital que mantiene la corriente
fluyendo en una sola dirección así que
déjame quitar esto que me tapa la luz
y bueno para que un led funcione debes
de tener una de estas cosas una
resistencia las resistencias existen
básicamente para cuidar que no fluya
demasiada corriente en el led y cause
que no se consuma antes de lo que se
supone que debe consumirse así que qué
te parece si investigamos qué tipo de
resistencia es cuál es el valor de esta
resistencia y para eso voy a sacar el
celular porque aquí tengo una aplicación
que me ayudará a descubrir cuál es el
código de resistencia esta es una manera
muy práctica de hacerlo solo tenemos que
observar la resistencia o memorizar cuál
es el código de colores de las bandas
que tienen la resistencia y así podremos
saber su valor así que vamos a verlo con
esta resistencia primero tenemos una
banda verde así que ponemos por aquí el
verde y después tiene una banda azul
marido vamos a ponerlo y una banda
dorada
o no no no cuidado espera espera no es
una banda dorada primero es una banda
negra lo siento y después ahora si es la
dorada
esta es una resistencia de 56 oms esta
es la cantidad de resistencia que la
resistencia proporciona y el interruptor
de aquí es un interruptor continuo eso
significa que cuando lo presionas este
se queda abajo y cuando lo deja subir se
queda arriba es así que la luz se
quedará encendida cuando los versiones y
bueno el circuito es extremadamente
simple básicamente tienes la energía de
las baterías entra a través de este
circuito después el interruptor
básicamente se abre cuando sube y te
tiene el flujo de energía cuando baja y
permite que la energía fluya en este
circuito continuo así que bueno esto es
lo que hay adentro de una lámpara de
toque y ahora vamos a quitar rápidamente
las baterías
estas son dobles
y bueno también puedes ver que el panel
posterior fue moldeado por inyección ya
que se pueden ver los pernos del
inyector justo por aquí estos son los
pernos que lo empujan fuera del molde y
parece que fue moldeado por inyección
esta vez no tiene la marca de
designación de plástico pero
probablemente es polipropileno o
plástico abs también puedes ver estos
contactos de adentro que probablemente
están hechos bueno al principio creía
que estaban hechos de acero pero vamos a
ver que no es así porque por aquí tengo
dos imanes y voy a tomar uno y se
observan los imanes no son atraídos por
estos contactos así que probablemente
son contactos de latón es decir de un
material que no es metal ferroso y ahora
puedes ver este aro de kim este aro de
plástico previene que la terminal
positiva de la batería se desliza hacia
abajo del contacto así que con este aro
permanece en contacto constante y se
mantiene todo juntos
y bueno pueden ver que hay otro de este
lado y bueno pues eso es todo es
prácticamente todo además tiene la
característica de que si tienes un
tornillo o un clavo en el muro puedes
colocar la lámpara de toque y colgarla
así pero bueno eso es todo al final esto
es prácticamente una lámpara de toque